ces murs carbonisé s'élève au dessus
d'un campus universitaire dévasté la
bibliothèque de l'université de mossoul
étaient autrefois des joyaux du
patrimoine culturel irakien et la bri
est l'une des plus grandes collections
littéraire du moyen-orient mais
aujourd'hui ces trésors
certains de ces ouvrages irremplaçable
sont réduites en cendres à barthez avant
la libération de mossoul les américains
ont bombardé la bibliothèque et trois
quatre jours plus tard le il a incendié
on voyait s'élever les flammes et la
fumée de partout à mossoul
j'étais déçue et attristée
ça m'a profondément blessé à chaque
étage des normes cratère causé par les
bombes de la coalition laisse pénétrer
une faible lumière sur une scène
désolante communication seules quelques
centaines de livres ont survécu au
brasier com ironiquement ce traité sur
l'art de la diplomatie pour un dialogue
ans en français pour un dialogue des
civilisations avec d'autres étudiants de
l'université hawass ibrahim s'est donné
pour mission de non seulement sauver le
peu de livres épargnés par l' incendie
mais de redonner vie à cet antre du
savoir et de la mémoire collective
nous sommes sortis de l'enfer et entrer
au paradis
c'est comme ça qu'on sent depuis que
nous sommes libérés de l'emprise de
l'eau y est nous avons la liberté celle
d'un homme qui peut dire et faire ce
qu'il veut peu importe ce qu'il pense
dow à l'américaine d'eau ça c'est la
liberté
alors tout ça ce qui est brûlé détruit à
mossoul
nous allons de rebâtir nous le pouvons
oui oui belote est un gain elle week-end
le groupe hermitage islamique avait déjà
détruit la bibliothèque centrale de
mossoul et incendie près de cent mille
livres en 2013 selon plusieurs témoins
les jihadistes ont aussi largement
publicisé ces vidéos mettant en scène la
destruction de sites anciens dont il
emplit contrôle en irak et en syrie
statut sanctuaire est cité antique
tout ce que le y percevait comme de
l'idolâtrie impie y est passé une
pratique qui a été décriée par l'unesco
comme un nettoyage culturel après la
libération de mossoul
la première chose à laquelle j'ai pensé
c'est comment commencer une nouvelle vie
une vie sans crime et tout de suite j'ai
pensé à lire des livres à tout le monde
en irak et à mossoul
c'est que les livres c'est la vie
les efforts pour faire renaître la
bibliothèque de l'université de ses
cendres sont pilotés par mossoul aïe
l'oeil de mossoul eu un blog dont
l'auteur anonyme a fait la chronique de
la vie quotidienne avec toutes ces
difficultés ces atrocités sous l'emprise
du groupe armé islamique
je suis en colère et je suis triste très
triste
j'ai perdu trois ans de ma vie c'est
pour ça que je suis si triste
tous les jeunes hommes les étudiants ont
perdu trois anglais
au delà des horreurs dont ils ont été
témoins tous ces jeunes hommes ont été
privés de ce qu'ils appellent les
plaisirs simples de la vie au cours des
trois dernières années
forcé de vivre leur passion en secret
comme issam un artiste peintre je
dessinais et je peignais en cachette
j'achetais mon matériel discrètement et
je devais me cacher sans en parler à
personne pas même à mes amis qui ne
savais pas que j'étais un artiste
quand j'ai vu l'armée irakienne ici et
qu'ils ont éliminés dèche
j'ai explosé et j'ai crié je suis un
artiste projet
[Musique]
plus difficile à l'époque 2e i c'est
l'absence de vie privée de liberté
si je parle avec quelqu'un l'extérieur
de mossoul je veux être suivie si le ca
si je parle avec mon cousin à l'étranger
je veux être tué
si je regarde la télé et qu'ils viennent
chez moi
une voix je vais être puni nous
n'allions pas à l'école n'avions rien lu
de bond prévu de bons films
c'est une ville que sans la fille la
bibliothèque est en quelque sorte un
microcosme des défis de reconstruction
qui attendent irak et pour ces jeunes
étudiants et il est un phare qui
symbolise la fin d'un obscurantisme
qu'il espère ne jamais revoir